hello there who's just efficiently
announced recently that the new Star
Wars movie will be coming out there is
no release date at the moment but
honestly this was a surprise to be sure
but a welcome one because you know I
wasn't expecting to get an announcement
for a new film today but we did so I'm
not complaining
anyway Tiger where tini will be
directing and co-writing this film he
was actually the director and rider for
JJ Robert which recently did win an
award for Best Adapted Screenplay and he
also did directs my favorite Mandalorian
episode which was the season finale
episode 8 so you know what I'm really
excited for us also joining him on this
project will be Christie Wilson Khans
who was the curve rider from 1917 she
will also be co-write in this film with
tyka you know they really got the right
people for this projects I'm really
excited and curious to see you know what
type of Star Wars movie will be will it
be set in the high republic will be part
of a trilogy I got no clue but either
way I'm really excited I'm pumped for
this the future for Star Wars is looking
bright
we got multiple TV shows come out Disney
Plus we now got movies Clone Wars just
finished and how to you what the end
into Clone Wars was absolutely perfect
like honestly it left me completely
speechless but anyway guys told me in
the comments below what you think tiger
star was film will be about or what
you're hoping it's going to be about and
also if you want more commentary videos
and news updates like this one do let me
know in the comments below as well bring
away guys that's about it for this video
so I'll catch you guys in the next one
and made a force be with you
[Music]